[Music]
everybody's Lord mobster here from Lords
of gaming dotnet I'm here at flat from
another indie studio yes so vigil the
longest night its indie game from
Taiwanese developers coming out later
this year it's a 2d side-scroller
eldritch Lovecraft horror Metroidvania
with very technical combat so it's not
just hack and slash you have to parry
dodge repose jump roll dodge that's not
that's not that sounds like right up my
alley so a lot with those kind of games
the enemy designs are always will blow
people out of the water so what can
people expect for vigil so it's a
mix-and-match with Taiwanese mythology
and medieval eldritch horror so you got
a bit of Asian culture and a bit of
Western culture and there's many
different bosses I think about you for
like 13 different big boss fights and
also branching paths so depending which
choices you make during the gameplay you
will have to fight different bosses
perfect first so tell us a little about
the level design - because you say
Metroidvania so let's actually look at
the love what's going on and that he's
playing for us right now right so first
you come back to your hometown so this
is like beginning of the woods and after
you pass the woods you will have like a
little mini boss fight to introduce the
basic mechanics and after that you get
to the village which is a big hub and
you explore that that's where you get
the clues about this story and what's
going on because you're looking for your
sister who disappeared and why the game
is called the longest night is because
one day the Sun went down and it never
came up so it is a perpetual night and
people started going crazy
there's mutation there's like baby Dima
and spikey dogs all of that crazy stuff
so as you progress through the game you
start unlocking different areas like the
catacombs the underground the graveyard
the church the sacred grounds the
waterfall so the scenery is very very
then you have to backtrack back and
forth after you unlock certain abilities
after defeating certain bosses and then
you also in the end up teleporting to
NetherRealm ish type of thing yes tell
us a little bit but the art style
because it's a very pretty game to look
at yes so the art style is like you see
do its parallax backgrounds and it's all
watercolor themed a bit like smudged out
but the main character Leia her
character is all it's a fully rendered
3d model so you have that contrast when
you fight with her the action is a lot
smoother and we can animate her movement
and different attacks better when it's a
free DVD model compared to the 2g
background so it gives that eerie spooky
feeling with a pastel coloring like a
painting but you'd still get the crisp
action with the 3d model of the
character well I'm really excited to get
my hands on this but when can other
people get be able to play visual we
actually just had an open beta in our
discs or the week before but the game is
launching later this year and we plan to
release the switch PlayStation Xbox and
PC perfect perfect thank you so much for
the information I'm Vishal again it's
looking great I hope that the
development goes smooth from here on out
anything anything else we want to say
about visual I know if you like what you
see wish list it on Steam thank you so
much all right
that's visual the longest night is Lord
mantra signing off and Lord forgave me
you
[Music]